all snakes are carnivores but certain
ones like this king cobra in southern
India have a predilection for other
snakes in this case a rat snake humans
often confuse the rat snake with the
Cobra and kill it but here's what's
different cobra big rat snake smaller
cobra capable of rearing up into scary
attack pose yeah rat snake not Cobra
venomous rat snake has none cobra are
ready to munch rat snake soon to be
lunch but not without a fight we can't
know what the Cobra is thinking but it's
got to be annoying when you're trying to
eat something and that something is
trying to bite you back now the king
cobra can be cannibalistic but if
another species is handy they're
preferable
king cobra venom kills the rat snake in
minutes in this amazing film footage we
see how one snake eats another ever see
kids attack a big plate of spaghetti
where they take one huge strand and suck
it into their mouths inch by inch by
inch to the horror of their parents
that's how the king cobra doesn't the
cobra can't chew its prey it swallows
the rat snake hole and then the strong
acids in its stomach go to work
ratsnake good to the last delicious
scale